it's it's kind of like the born-again
Virgin thing where it's like a guy that
is gonna wait for a girl that's slept
with other men for marriage like he's
kind of a simp and that's why guys are
leaving the church because they thought
they were going to get virgins and they
get girls that have slept with multiple
men the women are good
sometimes
because she knows something about it you
know what right A lot of people say the
women right but a lot of men go to
church just for sex no you're right
you're right but thanks to the women
they just leave them
but it's hard it's hard because like I
agree with you like I don't I don't
think people should sleep around right
like I'm with you but like at the same
time it's like I think a lot of times
the church leaves women single and you
see that because I walk into any church
of 70 to 80 women they're usually single
and and the thing is I meet a lot of
girls that are celibate you know and to
guys it just sounds like nonsense it's
like where what where was the celibacy
when you were your [__] Chad or
Tyrone or whoever it was
a man
I understand for you it seems a little
more like I think the younger girls are
a little bit more genuine because
they're they're younger when they do a
lot of girls get there at like 29 to 30
with a kid and they're like yeah I'm
gonna wait again and the guys are like
[__] that yeah that makes no sense but
and then this might be at a smaller
scale but it's like like a lot of times
I I do think the church leaves women
single because they tell them to be
celibate again but it's a bad deal for
men because they have to wait for a girl
to be like to get her to be married but
at the same time she gets all the
commitment I don't believe that go ahead
no no she's right she's right no she's
not because nobody forces the women to
go to sleep no no no no no no no no no
they go to church as a backslider Auntie
Jenny they go to church Auntie Jenny let
me ask you Jenny speak then they go to
church right the women go to church
thinking that they can hide in the
church and they can't hide in the church
they're only fooling themselves because
all they do some of the women is go
there to give their [__] a rest you
understand I'm not gonna say knock it is
so when they say
don't go to church but at the end of the
day they will go out there and sleep
with a whole heap of man
and then go when their front is too hot
and then go and say you know what I'm
gonna chill out in church and wait for a
man to come and that's what it is a
church is not a resting place for a hot
Fanny do you know what I mean
that's what it's there for if you decide
and honestly because I'm religious if
you decide that you had enough and you
want to go there but don't go and when
it when people go to church right after
having a relationship they think they
can go there and be born again no
they're not born again because you
already Born Again ain't no Boone again
you still have to remember all the men
that you've had and you start to deal
with all the men that you've had and you
have to be honest with the men that
you're gonna have or the future husband
so don't go to church and think that you
can hide away all the heads that you've
had and all the men that you've had
because you can't hide it you're fooling
yourself but even even if the girls are
honest in the church yeah they go to the
men and they say hey um this is what I'm
selling I'm a used Honda Civic here this
is I'm selling myself for new BMW prices
and the men are like
why would I do that when I could get
another used Honda Civic do you know
well the men need to go and get the
other Honda Civic because what the women
fail to realize is that there's a name
for women like that in church is it
monarch and there's women in there's
what they fail to realize is that when
all these women run to church right to
get away from it they don't realize that
there's some women in the Bible that
never have a man that always been in
church that will never ever ever have a
man and 90 of their women are gonna it's
like a religious leftover woman right
right you know I mean and that's what
they're gonna end up with I I know but
that's what I'm saying like a lot of
times when the church will encourage
women to wait till they're married after
they've had they're not virgins anymore
I think it leads to worse outcomes
because because again it's everywhere
Auntie I'm telling you I've had these
conversations with people in Christian
churches Catholic Church like it's
across the board walk into any church in
the west it's 70 to 80 women and and
this is why because from a reproductive
like mating strategy it gives all the
benefits to women and and all of the
responsibility on the men yes I mean I
go to church and I'm not hypocrite I go
to church regular I'm not taking nothing
taking nothing because I know as soon as
I come out of church I'm going to have
sex
Auntie Jenner you gotta realize yeah
woman's go to church here as what you
said to go arrest them India yeah but
what it's it's like when you lose I'm
going to use your example it's like when
you lose your family member you turn to
religion for comfort in it these women
go turn to the pastor for comfort and
the pastor starts talking and
brainwashing them to me church is a big
brain on sheets I don't need to go to
church to praise my God in it yes
actually then again brainwashing church
I know they said leftover that's why she
just said leftover oh wait no someone's
gonna come and get your mind don't worry
you're a brat don't Bentley from
the thing is right is that I find that
when the women want to go and find a man
right they will go all around the world
right they will go on holiday they would
look here and they would look there and
then when it comes to finding a man in
church they sit to the one church now
imagine
she said I go to a church and I don't
like it but I'm gonna where the hell are
you going to church that you don't like
there's obviously no money that you like
the whole world is your oyster I'm sure
that when you're at that lucky man you
look at them and the whole world so if
you want to find a man in it you got the
whole world of church she said go to a
Jamaican Church you're gonna find the
man that's because
why are you gonna stay in one church
when that church might not be right for
you are you saying there's multiple
strip clubs go to all of them and test
it out
I think they go to church or whatever
religious practice it is with the right
intention yeah they go there because
whatever they've been doing outside
hasn't been working yet and they want to
get closer to God even in within a
relationship marriage they want to do it
the right way yeah like the religious
way whatever that boom but I feel like
with women here with that kind of
comfortability now and familiarity with
the men what you're now constantly
around in church these men are still
still you know active aimed that there
you go and I feel like the familiarity
now that they've now built with these
men and this comfort and the safety they
feel around the Christian Brothers if
it's a Christian Church what happens now
is after a while you slip into the same
cycle but now it's just within a church
Community because not just within the
church you build like you join the group
chat now you're going out socially with
you know I mean different churches
different guys and now with that
familiarity it become comes easier for a
woman now to lie down and then what
happens you end up getting around how
you got around to the majority and it
runs you in the streets you'll end up
getting run to in church within the
church and when I say run to you it
don't have to be nothing mad like 20 man
it could be three or four yeah but but
that 304 is detrimental because it's
within the same community so now what
you're doing is your proper limit in
your charts of getting it that's why
what Paul said in the end the percentage
is very high which don't end up with the
ring because within your church
Community you know Marlon Aaron and John
has run through it so you're thinking
like no that's mad and you gotta go
Church work with the wife you know what
Marlon Jonas
like the point the point is like I don't
think telling women to wait after
they've had sex produces good outcomes
and I see this because I see there's so
many celibate girls in the church and
the ones I believe that like actually
are celibate it's like they're still
single and they're are so simple because
again they're selling a used Honda Civic
for new prices how come we're not
talking about the men you see my best
friends right because because the
problem is men and women are different
and women don't care if a guy slept with
a lot of people but we just okay like
this is kind of a need to be right and I
think on an innate level you know that
it's true because we just talked to the
girls on the couch just in this
conversation the men said by and large
they tended to want virgins where we
tended to want men that have slept with
other women and it's just true and it's
not it's not fun like it's not a fun
part of being a woman but it just it is
what it is like the women have
consequences for that stuff men get more
chicks who's lining up to for Drake and
saying oh did he sleep with too many
girls no
Britney Runner they're running from in
general it's like a trophy for like a
woman to have to have that man for a
woman to get wiped by a man that the
majority of women want it's like a
trophy like he chose me
in the majority like you you wanted the
popular kid that majority of the girls
probably because majority of the girls
wanted it but in majority men wanted
that one well yeah none of that man them
has touched it you don't want the one
that who demand them has wants to go
through and you want the one that none
you know what I'm trying to say you know
they need to realize right that church
ain't nowhere for counseling people
always say that oh yeah my funny had
trauma and I went
I mean everybody's got trauma nowadays
as far as I'm concerned get some
counseling for your funny trauma funny
trauma oh you're funny because that's
why they have all this funny trauma and
then they go to church trying to relieve
it Jeremy because I gotta speak because
I got a friend and she's been in the
church for like I don't know about 30
years and she ain't got no man and you
know what she never went to church
looking for no man so she don't expect
to go because she never went to church
with funny trauma do you know what I
mean so she always went to church she
said if a man that was a man if a man
comes along fine I never it's a eunuch
that's the word and if a man doesn't
come along I said to her you're a unit
he goes why are you putting it on that
me I I've still got time to find the man
after this one give up my name you're
eunuch do you know what I mean some
women go to church and they're going to
church thinking that yeah all women are
supposed to find men in church no some
of the women are supposed to be single
in church for 30 40 years unless you do
your research so when you go to don't go
to church trying to get cancer for
yourself but they say to be fruitful and
multiply you don't you don't think it's
going a little bit against God to not
get with a man if you're over so if
you're over 30 years old who wants to go
football for no bag it seemed like
having a
leftovers you know you just said you
knock here that's used for a term that
older woman that has never kidding it
and she can't have a kid no more so she
it's like it's like the term they use
when a woman hit the menopause I'm glad
you said that they're done
yeah
you know I thought that was um someone
that didn't have a dick no yeah
you understand what I'm saying though
right yeah so it's like it's like you
should be able to go to church they
should be able to go to church and free
it up
is women single because they encourage
them to wait till they're married after
they've had sex and what and what kind
of guy is going to do that when he knows
you banged the three dudes down the
street
because I don't see no one dragging the
women into church
I don't see no one so the church don't
turn around and say to women oh come
here we're gonna find the man for you
it's the women with their funny trauma
that decide to go to church so the
church don't make them stay there if
they will get cancer for their family
trauma half of them women if they got
counseling before they were interjected
but yet they're still screwing around
because they get counseling about the
one guy that broke their heart and then
they will move on they wouldn't be in
church so I don't I won't say blame the
church because at the end of the day
nobody gets forces into church they go
they have their own free will no they go
there because they figure themselves oh
all these men outside are treating me
bad I'm gonna come in here and find some
stupid Christian guy that's gonna take
me as I am because you don't care about
body care you know what those are the
eunuchs of the future those are the
leftover women
and I agree with you I'm just saying
like like this stuff to men it kind of
reports and this is just feedback I've
gotten because I I kind of had the same
view as you before I just started
listening to guys talk more and it's
like from the men's point of view it's
like you're encouraging these girls to
wait again but what do we get out of it
we don't get a virgin Brad why would we
do that and so and so stuff like that
makes men want to not go to church I use
a church leader you want to ask them men
how many how many of them guys go into
church and [__] the girls and come back
out without everything a little man go
to church
yes
I actually I have a whole Theory as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible possible